Do you want to do something that makes you feel alive?
(Excited screaming)
Now that I beat cancer, I'm done letting fear
stop me from living.
(Hayley Kiyoko singing)
I am playing Ella McCaffrey.
Now that treatment's over.
She knows that you have to live life to the fullest
because you only get one chance.
I think I crossed, like, ten things off my bucket list
today.
Cannonball!
This show is about growing from
something that is traumatic and something that's hard.
That's the thing that inspires us.
An emotional time in your life doesn't necessarily
need to break you. It could make you into something better.
I'm not wasting my chance at life.
You are the toughest 13 year old I've ever known.
(Music playing)
Kai is my best friend in the show.
Kai is this loving, very funny, best friend of Ella's.
I've always got your back.
She's doing something.
I'm right there with her.
I'm going to hit the stairs.
Kai, we're in this together.
Ella's trying to teach Kai how to not be scared
because she used to be the same way that Kai was.
Do you want to go again?
Absolutely.
Ella! You're here!
Ella: Hey, Ximena.
Ximena: I missed you so much.
Ximena was Ella's best friend before cancer,
and they were so close.
When Ella got cancer., Ximena wasn't really there for her.
It made Ella feel like Ximena didn't care about her
when that wasn't actually the truth.
She felt really bad, and she was trying to do
all the things that they used to do as a kid, but
she had to work on herself a little bit.
I love Ella's family.
Photobomb!
Grady, my brother, he's a little nut.
I may or may not have half a hanger stuck in my cast.
Grady, you know, he used to love his life,
but then as soon as she got
sick, all the attention went to Ella.
I think I've had enough of this....Ella-bration.
So he uses bad behavior to get attention.
Hey, Dad.
He and his family decided that he's going to be
the one that stays at home to help her heal.
He can be a little too "helicopter-y"
I can't breathe.
He wants to make sure that she stays healthy and safe.
Seriously, Dad? Is that a laminated card
with all of my allergies?
And your blood type.
Mom?
Hey!
What I love about Joanne
is she lets Ella make her own decisions.
Mom...save me.
Carl, let her be a kid.
She tries her best to really express support,
but let Ella find her own way.
What do you want to do?
I want to make some new memories.
(Hayley Kiyoko music plays)
The show has taught me so much
about not being afraid of the what ifs in life.
(Hayley Kiyoko sings)
You don't want to have any of those regrets.
Like, I wish that I wasn't scared to do that.
(Hayley Kiyoko music plays)